what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time well while
she's trying to get rich to us let's
just try to get our lunch money right
i'm here with paulina forget the rest of
her name just paulina that's it she's
gonna take over that word
and i don't know what is going on here
i've got a forest growing out of my head
i told you guys when i got this haircut
it just keeps growing and growing and
growing i can't keep it down
whatever we're just gonna go with it i
look like an idiot with it
a shower doesn't matter just gotta get
yourself some gel and hairspray
no i just need to go get a real haircut
like a regular haircut not a crazy
haircut
uh don't forget that lunch money is now
sponsored by block five block five has
a interest bearing account where you can
earn eight point six percent apy
why does that matter because in your
checking in your savings account
you can earn like three basis points or
five basis points that's like 0.03
or 0.05 percent but with block five you
can earn eight point six percent
pelina is over here yawning that's not
good
but don't worry 8.6 apy in an interest
bearing account there's risk but i'm an
investor i did my diligence i like it
i'm a user you should go use the product
check out blockby.com
jpmorgan chase the ceo
jamie dimon said he's not against higher
taxes on the rich but a wealth tax is
not the way to do it
he said it's almost impossible to do um
this this tax has been put forward in a
proposal by several democrats
and he said i'm not against having a
higher tax on the wealthy but i think
that you do that through their income as
opposed to you know calculate wealth
which becomes extremely complicated
legalistic bureaucratic regulatory and
people find a million ways around it
i would just tax income makes a lot of
sense
it's really really hard to do the wealth
tax and even forbes struggles to do it
so
well they're trying to calculate wealth
so that that's difficult obviously
that's what they're going to try to do
no but it becomes difficult because what
do you do in a situation
let's say that uh i own a stock for
example whether i bought it or i'm just
like the founder of a company
and it appreciates significantly in
price so for example when they're like
oh the richest people in america
gained you know 800 billion dollars
during the pandemic
yeah they didn't get 800 billion dollars
of cash it's the stock prices all went
up
so let's say at the end of this year uh
somebody whether you're
a kind of an average citizen or you're a
billionaire
if you're stock appreciated at the end
of the year they say okay
you owe us uh 20 of that
money okay but you don't have the cash
so
what they would do then they would force
you to sell the stock
in order to then go pay them right
because it's part of your net worth has
gone up but you didn't actually get the
cash with an income
tax you actually have the cash to pay
and so
if you that's in a liquid market you
could sell the stock and kind of raise
capital to do it
but then what happens if you're uh in a
private uh
situation so let's say you bought a home
you own the homeowners you've been able
to pay off your home
it's by far your biggest asset that you
own and your house appreciates
um by twenty thousand dollars this year
okay
are they then gonna tax you on the 20
gain of your house
you you don't have the money how do you
pay so you so the wealth tax
is really really hard to implement and
then what people can do is they can do
they can manipulate it a million
different ways
whereas with income it's straightforward
and so i think that
uh he's dead on with this in terms of
how to actually do it
but it goes back to do you remember what
we talked about uh it's probably like
june or july
every single year for the last six
fiscal years the government has brought
in
record level of federal income tax
revenue so they keep
collecting more right the income is
going up but the
annual deficit that they're running is
getting wider and wider and wider
so it's not a income problem it's not a
revenue problem right
the government is collecting enough
money it's that we spend
on the dumbest stuff in the world and
we're super inefficient
look at i this is an interesting part so
joe biden has said that he would roll
back most of trump's multi-million
dollar tax cuts which some reports said
benefited businesses and higher income
individuals the most
but diamond said the president's tax
policies are among some of the very good
things that he's done for the us economy
he explained that the u.s has
traditionally been a red tape society
with a bureaucracy that slows down a lot
of business
and he said and i remind people the
world when you slow down the economy
you're hurting the disadvantaged more
than anybody else
so is that because they they're not
paying
more taxes so why are they being
disadvantaged because the businesses are
getting her
and therefore the economy look what
happened when the pandemic happened that
we stopped the economy
who are the people who get hurt the
people who work service jobs and hourly
wage workers they're the ones who get
fired first
right then they don't have access to
capital they can't pay their rent
like there's all these issues because
again what they're basically doing is
almost think about it as uh they're
basically running through life
right it's kind of like the rat race and
when they're doing that they don't have
emergency funds if for some reason they
lose their job
or to pay rent they can't take a month
off from work right because they need
that paycheck
and so they're literally running uh
basically
a uh a non-profitable business if you
think of it that way right
their income and their expenses barely
match and sometimes actually they run a
deficit that's where they get credit
card debt things like that
and so when you think through that it's
just you have to keep
capital flowing to these people uh
what i i honestly believe this right and
this is not a political statement at all
as many people know i hate both
political parties uh
i just think that we spend an inordinate
amount of money
on dumb [ __ ] that's the best way i can
say the government
there was a uh in one of the stimulus
packages earlier this year
i like a nerd went and i read through
some of it and these things are
you know hundreds of pages one of the
things that was being debated
and was a hold up to getting it approved
at one point was whether they were going
to
approve 25 million
for cleaning supplies for the i think it
was the capitol building
in washington d.c you need cleaning
supplies you need cleaning somebody you
need 25 million dollars worth
come on i know a lot of people that you
could say hey we're gonna go and we're
gonna clean this for one year
for one year and we're gonna pay you
less than 25 million dollars to do it
and you've got to bring your own
supplies and they'll clean the [ __ ] out
of the capitol building
right so it's just things like that are
like the really easy things
and then when you get into all these
organizations uh and you start to look
at like how effective
actually are they it it really varies
like there's a lot of organizations we
probably could get rid of
and drastically reduce the uh federal
spending
and still be okay that's what i think
all right
what's next so at his battery event
yesterday elon musk promised a 25
000 tesla electric car that would be
available in three years
and he said that it would be
capable of driving fully autonomously
i mean remember how yesterday you said
he was like tampering expectations i
feel like this is pretty big
yes but he says it's not gonna be
available for three years so
well i think that's what he basically
was when he tweeted out he was just
saying like look this is going to be
exciting but he was trying to set the
expectation that like it's not actually
going to get into production until 2022
or 2023 so it looks like that's
basically what they are uh
are getting to the crazy part is
he's been saying this for a while that
he's gonna be able to do it
and how much is a tesla now well they
start out very expensive so his whole
business model was
sell like a really um kind of
aspirational sports car
so really high price point great margins
it gave them the cash they needed to be
able to build out
um the technology etc and then he
started to come down in price point i
think the cheapest one you can buy now
is around fifty thousand dollars
still pretty expensive for a car uh if
you can get this down to 25
again like that's not the cheapest car
but it's way better than i think they
started selling the original ones at
like 100 plus thousand dollars
musk also announced that tesla is taking
orders now for a new
three motor tesla model s with plaid
mode
a version capable of producing 1100
horsepower
this car will be able to go from zero to
60 miles an hour in under two
seconds and run a quarter mile drag
strip in nine seconds
costing about 140 thousand dollars
yeah it's really crazy how he's been
able to from a market standpoint
uh like lamborghini ferrari right i
think his lamborghini's got this great
uh line where they say we don't do a tv
advertisements because our customers
aren't sitting at home watching tv
right so they're basically appealing to
kind of the aspirational
wealthy uh running ads well they would
never
sell a car for twenty five thousand
dollars because it would ruin the brand
yeah
right and so what uh tesla's been able
to do is sell both
uh cars for high price points 100 140
000 and also now come out with a 25 000
car it's really interesting how they can
kind of navigate that uh and still keep
that brand power
awesome speaking of cars speaking of
cars
carvana uh is a
car used car com used car yeah used car
company
stop it it's so ridiculous go ahead come
on
carvana is a used car company and it's a
father and son team
bernie garcia ii and ernie garcia iii
the third and the second
you think they call each other eg2 and
eg3
so his son garcia iii is the company's
ceo
together they're worth 21.4 billion
dollars
shares of the company searched 31 on
tuesday
after it projected record revenue and
profit margins the stock has rallied
almost 150
this year as americans have turned to
buying household essentials
and increasingly used cars online
every big purchase you make is now going
online who would have thought 10 years
ago that you'd buy a car online without
ever seeing it
buy a home online without seeing it sell
your home
to somebody like an open door
everything's going online online
transactions are going to be
the standard carvana lets you choose for
more than 19 000
cars and complete purchases in as little
as 10 minutes
it's crazy that you can buy like you
know a coffee maker
on the internet and then also a car just
put it put it on my cart
3.9 billion in revenue last year they
sold 200 000 cars
it's cool you don't hear about these
guys yeah well trust me
ernie garcia ii and ernie garcia three
are going to the
bank because they billy boys all right
what's next
terminology billy boy are you gonna make
that sound you made yesterday again
no okay come on
that's what it was digiday
editor-in-chief
uh brian morrissey is leaving the
company at the end of the month guess
what he's leaving to do
what is the editor-in-chief of digiday
go home and hang out with his kids write
a newsletter on the rebooting of
media is he gonna do it on substance
unclear
but probably casey newton just left the
verge and is going to substance wait
really yep oh i did not know that bang
bang
wow that's big and i tweeted i said if
software's eating the world then
subsect's eating the newsroom
wait is soft if software is eating the
world then substance eating the newsroom
it's a it's a no-brainer for people to
leave if you're a reporter why would you
stay
oh okay you have an editor suite you
know how to write you don't need it well
you need an editor a lot of a lot of
these people need editors yes you do
for the really really good stuff like
what i do is i sometimes
email my friends who have been in
journalism for a long time and i ask
them to look it over
you can find ways around it but i think
hopefully in the future
subsequent offers something like that
that would be great all right let's keep
going by the way while she's
transitioning on the pages somebody
called me a writer yesterday and pelina
and i
lost it we literally could not stop
laughing
because somebody's like oh yeah he's
such a good writer and it was like
if you think i'm a writer you lost you
confused you lost in the sauce
did you like that lost in the sauce come
on mark cuban
mark benioff robert downey jr gwyneth
paltrow and uber ceo
dara um
are investing in toilet paper what
led by great great croft a who's who of
celebrities
including all these people russell
wilson ashley kutcher
all of them are investing three million
dollars into a new toilet paper brand
called cloud paper
they're it's a toilet paper brand that's
hoping to save the environment
i mean honestly cloud paper sounds like
that you know if you got to wipe your
butt and feel good
it's one of several companies trying to
get consumers to make the switch of
bamboo based toilet paper
but it may only be to get such high
profile investors to flush it
with wads of cash what a bad joke
so yeah and i like it they're one of
their pages says we roll
different and that's pretty good so
basically
toilet paper is a key contributing
factor to climate change according to
the oh
sorry sorry deforestation not toilet
paper
15 of deforestation is due to toilet
paper production alone
and roughly 40 000 trees per year are
cut down for us consumers
to wipe their butts it just says wipe up
but he added that watch okay honest all
right what's next
so there's a zombie storm named
paulette that is regaining some strength
according to weird
2020 weather it's a zombie storm called
paulette there's also a zombie monster i
live with called polina
[Laughter]
so um yeah it's a zombie storm
so what does that mean it's an unusual
phenomenon
one that comes during an extremely busy
fuzzy
busy hurricane season in a year that has
been chock full of extremes
do you think we live in a simulation no
well i think that just means that it's
weird i really do think that uh it's a
zombie tropical storm i really do think
we could be living in a
simulation and somebody just like they
got drunk and they're like
watch this it's kind of like when you're
playing a video game and you're not
trying to win the game anymore
you're just screwing around and like you
know just trying to hang out how do you
think the aliens are playing
i don't know but like if you're trying
to screw around this would be hilarious
right oh let's do a pandemic
press a button like idiots watch them
react to this okay here comes a zombie
storm
like oh let's put a meteor real close
like
oh let's find a t-rex so
so i one of my friends tweeted and he
said
oh my god there's a meteor meteor
meteor yeah four million miles away
except he did
four m miles and i read that and i was
like oh my god it's four miles away i
missed the m
and i was really nervous for a second
and then i saw the million i was like
hey
you're not scared no i'm ready for the
simulation
what simulation are you ever seeing
where they break out of the video game
no i'm in there let's go all right
what's next all right
your joke my joke oh i got a great joke
for you guys today nope
i got a great joke are you ready i did
some research last night and i had to
when i searched for immature jokes i was
dying laughing
all night but i can't say most of them
on this show cause kids show you know
kid show
so what's six inches long two inches
wide and drives
women wild huh huh huh
a hundred dollar bill don't get it don't
be having any dirty minds out there just
a hundred dollars
um okay well you don't think that's
funny someone named tyler had a great
idea to do
uh this day in history instead of jokes
so
today in this tyler must be no fun
tyler's great
and tyler literally tyler you don't like
jokes no
this isn't nervous he said this isn't a
nerd program he said it would be
interesting
the youngest girl to fly across the u.s
happened today in 1993
eleven-year-old vicki van meter lands in
san diego after her three-day flight
from maine
the following year she became oh no she
became the youngest female pilot
to cross the atlantic somebody is giving
an 11 year old and a 12 year old
ability the ability to fly my parents
wouldn't even let me stay at home alone
when i was 11 years old that sounds like
some
i was staying home earlier than that
really
yeah when i was 11 years old there was
zero chance
zero my parents were still getting
babysitters this happened until he was
23 years old
no i literally think i was like probably
13 years old
and me and all my brothers my parents
would like go out uh
to like dinner or something my parents
would still get a babysitter
yeah they did there was no trust in it
are you kidding me me at 11 alone at
home we would have set the place on fire
i believe it i believe it that man i've
been why
at 11 years old but a plane
yeah isn't that cool
i mean why do you want your kid to be
such an overachiever just let him go be
an idiot on the internet
she liked flying do you know what you
like at 11 yes
i don't know i was just trying to get
fat eat bad food play video games with
my friends and hope my parents didn't
get me in trouble all right that's fine
cool whatever lunch money for today bang
bang while she's trying to get rich
let's just try to get a lunch money
right
we'll see you tomorrow maybe i'll get a
haircut
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find up to 8.6 percent
interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account go do your own research there's
risk associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfy
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends